when I started doing stand-up again
somebody mentions like you kind of ride
me of like bilborough's like I don't
know who bill where it was cuz I only
listen to black stand-up comedians yeah
at the time yeah it was only like the
station first
yeah like Eddie Merc there was no like
Korean like stand-up for me that I could
look up to besides Bonnie Lee at the
time yeah I know how much [__] cloud
is he must have it he's the only one he
doesn't even know it either
now I keep telling the dude last like
bro you were my hero they need those
like I don't understand I'm not that
dope and I'm like dude you had the
lowest self-esteem for somebody who has
influenced so many Asian people there's
no muscles in his body you know that you
know it's all [__] gristle it's
amazing what even his skeleton together
Rohit definitely like if they cut him
open it of buffet it would be a dessert
you know what is this oh you can hug him
and completely reshape him do not
squeeze him on the side the other day
and he was like for the rest of the day
like four inches taller
he's so malleable that dudes like he
cracked me up man is the only one yeah
he says some wild [__] dude and he ain't
afraid of that stuff too that's true and
I've always like loved his stand-up you
know it's it's it's not like the
stand-up that I normally like which is a
little bit more precise yeah I mean
because he's a little bit out there he's
a little bit more showy yes but like
it's so genuine I gently swell that's
why I love his podcast so much yeah I
mean he's authentic yeah and I've
probably liked his podcast more than I
like to stand up which I didn't think
was possible yeah just because like for
him it's not even making jokes he's just
a weird dude yeah he's just crazy and
he's wearing all that [__] like he's
trying to flex his nuts I was over there
two days ago there we are right there
and he's trying to flex his [__] nuts
and they added those shorts in I didn't
wear those shorts I generate bobby
shorts are real feel sir yeah Bobby
shirt - real they also edit in a lot of
[__] [__] in his pants
yes whole watermelon in there oh yeah
that's actually that his dick that's his
ball sack because I saw that [__] real
like his dick is very sad-looking his
his ball sacks are huge so we were i
sure a dark to my god man you would
think there was something wrong with
like his balls are holding their breath
yeah I guess we were we did a live
podcast and I was a guest and he's got
but Nick and I started grinding up on it
dude yeah and from the backside I could
see his ball sack like like they were
trying to run away
you know I mean they were so long long
balls a very long very quail is almost
it's almost something he's giving birth
to like a little baby duck you know it's
like that it's more of an amniotic sac
and his ball his ball sac legit looks
like that last drop on a faucet that
wants to fall down yeah you know it was
just kind of dangling me and then you
just SPECT it just fall out I was kind
of surprised I was like I've never seen
so much ball sac from behind something
yeah before and he puts up I know he
said he puts pine scent on his nut
sometimes which i think is fascinating
for an Asian person to even use pine
it's just such a simple old-school kind
of you know I found that this bee and
anyone use pine you know one of those
like interesting Korean dudes man like
he kind of made me feel when I was a kid
that I wasn't the odd person out anymore
that's interesting like there's other
Korean people out there that's kind of
like me that can be silly yeah that
could be silly that's not so serious all
the [__] time
Wow you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options watch
one this one